and welcome to the podcast i'm horny
uh when's the last time you had sex
uh
probably about literally
three
three or four weeks three weeks
ago and i like uh
sexually
did not do well
so
[Music]
how did you not do well
um i
flaccidly uh
um
exposed myself
lastly you're exposed to a flashlight
are my legs in the shot a little bit
sorry about the blindness
it looks whimsical because it doesn't
touch
so it looks like you're a kid
um
so grounded yeah so how are you doing
i perform sexually today whoa today yeah
this morning why did you call me
um
i mean i don't think that send a
postcard at least
um i mean maybe like
you think you would ever have a
threesome with a dude
yeah definitely
why i would have a threesome with three
dudes
so you're a little gay
uh no i i uh
i would have a threesome with i would
have like
i think yeah i mean a threesome maybes
maybe he's a bit too intimate i feel
like
a giant orgy with just like like
six
60 dudes like 70 girls
yeah maybe you wouldn't want 59 girls
because i'd be gay
yeah yeah 60 dude 60 girls
six maybe yeah
yeah that's a good ratio um i mean
orgies are great i've never been in one
but i'm sure they are
i'll give it a shot yeah
um
they're uh they're good for your
health
they're good for
uh
yoga positions
it's like pressure because people are
watching you i'd be the one dude in the
orgy just doing yoga
just
i'm like oh that's cool i'll just
stretch yoga looks like sex
just sex alone yeah yeah it's just
different sex positions very sexual
you're basically [ __ ] yourself
you're [ __ ] the universe
yeah you're letting the universe [ __ ]
you
um
do you uh
so that's funny like if you're in an
orgy and you're like i don't have a
partner it's like uh
musical chairs
and you're left out that round yeah i
know you're like hey yoga
uh you know i'll get uh
i'll be on standby
because
like you're just some people are [ __ ]
and you're just like do you need help
you want me to hold this they're like
get out of here they have chips
in the uh break room
you guys want some watermelon
cut up some oranges yeah i'll just uh
i'll just watch
you have like a whistle
all right switch it up and then like
nobody's listening to you no hair
pulling
all right that's a figure
do you feel respected right now i don't
think she's respected
try to take over
yeah um
so anybody need any uh gatorade or
nuts
in your face all right hustle in hustle
in
the model
uh john i like what you're doing but
would you want to watch instead as i
[ __ ] your girlfriend
here no this is what you need to do you
just kind of
and you're doing good you're doing it
you're almost there you know you just
kind of need to a little bit you know
let me use your girlfriend as an example
let me let me just tell show her use her
to show you how to [ __ ] that's what like
a lot of like people like that do is
they like or like yoga instructors or
something they'll like try to [ __ ]
people's girlfriends
because like
they're like trying to like flex their
power or something
yeah
i mean
that's hot if you could [ __ ] someone's
girlfriend i think that's eve that's uh
conniving yeah it's definitely not good
karma
um [ __ ] other people's girlfriend
it's like so forbidden it's like oh we
shouldn't be doing this
so like i mean just [ __ ] like an animal
or something
um
a [ __ ] animal yes that's what you're
looking for is like
instead of [ __ ] someone's girlfriend
[ __ ] animal
yeah
at least an animal doesn't have feelings
do you think they can hear us
who
they instagram yeah um yeah instagram
models
the thoughts
uh
so yeah um
have you ever been cheated on
no
hello hello
um
i've cheated in
yeah
i don't know yeah i mean uh i'm like uh
i don't really get into very
you know
uh
salt solo
or uh
relationships
yeah uh
so i don't i don't really i felt like
i've been cheated
i was cheated on actually
did you just remember that or
it's like on an on and off again
relationship so it's like was i in a
relationship with her when i [ __ ] when
she [ __ ] the dude
and then yeah definitely towards the end
and what did you do
i just was like
i felt like that you tried to push it
away the pain no i was yelling i was
getting angry you turned into the hulk i
forget what i did i just
yelled
um actually i was cool with that at the
end where what was the other guy like
um
he was
kind of
a fat loser he was a fat loser yeah
oh
which made a good better yeah but also
worse that's like bittersweet yeah it's
like
okay i mean i'm obviously the better man
but why did you [ __ ] him
yeah it's like being defiled it's like
she [ __ ] the dog
well that's what you want to do
yeah i was jealous i was envious
ah that was supposed to be me [ __ ] a
dog
yeah like my windows open all those
girls
getting to live out my fantasy of
[ __ ] dudes that's why i'm really
angry
because all these girls get to [ __ ]
dudes and i have to watch them and be
jealous do you wish that you had a
vagina
no
yeah sometimes like
when i'm like when there's like
a
a rail and i'm like
a rail
yeah
like a
metal rod yeah like a fence or like a
guardrail like a handrail
it looks like it'd be fun to rub your
vagina
on a rail
wouldn't that feel good yeah i mean i
would think more like uh
something smaller or less metally
less metallic
like a dick
yeah i mean uh that must feel way more
intense like being
having something inside of you than
putting something inside of something
yeah like buy they have more [ __ ] by
nature they got a [ __ ] and it's more
advanced spot
they got a whole you know modded
gaming pc down there
they have ph balances
they have
[ __ ]
you know
flaps
they have to uh yeah
they have to like
call people to like fix
go to like the gynecologist instead of
playing they have fluids
it's like a lot of a lot of maintenance
it's like it's like a bm like an old bmw
you know it's like it takes a lot of
work but it's worth it in the end yeah
the penis is like like a toyota corolla
where it's just like you know it's
always work it it's always running it's
always there
but you know
it's not as nice you know it's not like
it's not like it's intricate yeah it's
like everyone has one it's like a base
model you know yeah it doesn't have a
sunroof it's
yeah a vagina has subwoofers
it has
leather interior
yeah it has like a
power steering like uh yeah it has a lot
of [ __ ]
yeah
it you can take it has one of those
orgasms it has one of those windshield
wipers on the back window
you know when you see those and you're
like damn dude
that's not that's like wow yeah it's not
even necessary she's got like
she's got a wiper on her [ __ ]
that would be nice that's a good
invention yeah
it just comes and wipes wipes away all
the [ __ ] you don't even need a bidet
yeah it's like a
something
a power
wash or a automatic
sensor for
the windshield wipers for your [ __ ]
wipers
yeah
so uh i was at the gym just now
and uh did you go to the gym yeah i went
yesterday what oh yeah yes planet
fitness
planet hitness
planet your highness
princesses there do you enjoy working
out of the gym
uh
no
i don't
i think it could be way better
less sweaty
i just feel like it's industrial and
it's just like it's not fun
it's like just like these little rigid
areas and everything's metal it's not
like a field where you can play
yeah i don't like it because like
no matter where you are at the gym
like working out you're always gonna be
like making eye contact with someone
like while you're like lifting weights
like there's someone in your direction
and it's like yeah it's very
performative i feel so exposed you know
every time like i'm like working out
like lifting weights for myself
uh
and
i'm like i don't like don't stop looking
at me like i don't want you
this isn't for you
this isn't supposed to be at you and i
know it looks like i'm lifting weights
in your direction but you're just there
you know yeah and it's uh
it can be sexual
it's very sexual
everyone's like wearing the sexiest
things possible yeah like skid tight
clothes and like we're supposed to
bulging muscles yeah we're supposed to
act like you know like oh we're just
working out i'm just i'm just doing my
own thing
but yeah meanwhile it's all these hot
people in this sweaty room that's where
hot people go to get hotter
yeah so they're gonna they're in the
they're in the shop getting hotter and
you're like oh look this one's almost
done already
this one just sounds already hot stick a
toothpick in it yeah just a little bit
more
i noticed that there's a lot of women
who wear hats or dudes a lot of people
wear hats at the gym yeah put it really
low yeah why what is that
they just want to be a body they want to
like look out and stare and like not
make too much eye contact but they want
everyone to look at their body and so
they wear like really like showy clothes
but then they have the hat over to like
shame like it's like oh i'm being
anonymous with how sexy i am but i'm
still being sexy huh
yeah yeah because i have noticed like
the flat brim hats everyone's wearing
those yeah it's too intense the eye
contact
right
i mean yeah maybe that is a good idea
or just to wear a hat and
maybe just like a
something entirely on your face
that's what we should just do like a
mask yeah like a like a helmet
like a space helmet
a modesty helmet
uh
be wearing like a thong
and like a little tank top that covers
your nipples but then have like a space
helmet on and cover your whole face
because your face is more embarrassing
you can't work out your face
and then your face the whole time it's
just like
you got the ugliest face
and uh
yeah and like we all want to look at
each other
yeah
it should be
even outside of the gym it should be
socially acceptable to just stare at
someone
um
like
yeah
mean i don't like that i don't like that
much either everyone likes staring at
other people nobody likes
being stared up by someone
who is looking at you like in like a
creepy way
yeah
just have your boundaries just act like
it's like a museum just observe move on
yeah just get what you need three
seconds one two three okay maybe leave a
comment on like a comment card yeah
or you could like just
have their bio
like just scan people's qr code yeah
and you can download their biometrics be
like oh that person gave me this much
pleasure feels good next person
yeah you're like
and then there's occasionally people
were just like
hmm what does it really mean it's like
dude
you're do you're digging too deep into
it
yeah like just stop just go you do not
have access to these files
these require clearance of high security
yeah like what is their spirituality and
what does their butthole smell like
do not access denied
please ask her on a date first
get her a cup of coffee
i think it's better than beer
really
i just think everyone's like oh it's a
beer it's like the thing i'll grab you a
beer let's grab a beer let's be
having beers and it's like
are we just drinking this fluid because
we think we have to do we actually want
to
yeah beer is nice
a nice beer like a tart beer oh man it's
great and like it uh it livens up the
conversation you get loose
you're just drinking this
and coffee is just like by the end of
the conversation you're just like uh-huh
yeah
and you're like what what about that
jittery at the beer you're like yeah
yeah
yeah you're a [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] i mean i don't do that
after one beer
maybe like
eight
i guess if you're just slightly buzzed
you're like slightly stupid you're like
oh what yeah
yeah we're here oh we're in the moment
well it's just like yeah like it it
turns into like a child almost
you're like it like it takes away like
social boundaries yeah
you get to be
an
idiot who drank this thing that
makes your brain malfunction like
like you got hit in the head you want to
go get hit in the head so we can
communicate
on a non-intellectual level
and uh and coffee is just like by the
end of it you're just like thinking too
much you're like trying to be relaxed
like it's a date but then you're just
like getting like amped up
yeah i don't know i don't know i don't
know
that's what i say on dates i don't know
every answer the question i don't
know you know what is knowledge i think
you're asking me a lot of questions and
i just assumed that i'm an ignoramus
and that way i found a lot of success in
life it's so funny on dates like you're
both trying to act like you know
everything you're like
you're both trying to like act like you
know a lot
yeah
and it's so funny like being kind of a
stupid person
like
uh talking to other people who are like
like me yeah who would just like
try to make things more than they are
it's just like we we get to see each
other's [ __ ] like we both don't know
anything
like yeah you know what i mean yeah
you guys are like
trying to pretend to be adults
um
we are
yeah
i don't know yeah
it's like there's two types of people
there's ones that know
and are certain and then there's ones
that are uncertain
and
majority people are uncertain so it's
like two uncertain people talking to
each other it's just like
it's just like a a waste of time
basically
yeah it should be certain people talking
to
uncertain people and certain people
talking to certain people certain people
shouldn't be talking to any people
certain people need to move out of our
neighborhood
um
but yeah i mean maybe you could find out
new ways to be uncertain like oh i
thought i was certain about this but you
just found you just found a new way for
me to be unsure of this as well and you
can expand your uncertainty
you can both be uncertain but about oh
yeah whoa what if we're uncertain about
this
yeah
i don't know what the thing is
i love the way how i love how uncertain
you are about certain things i love how
you just don't know anything
you're so relaxed yeah
it's kind of my thing i uh don't know
certain things
i know some things but not a lot of
things you need a certificate about how
certainly uncertain you are you're
certainly uncertain
what a weird word
cervix
sartain
ascertain luberderm ascertain how
ascertain i am
anyways
what do you think about
um
[Music]
the austin comedy scene and our rise to
power in austin
austin comedy rise to power
2
k
two the power is risen
um
i think that it's a really good thing
and like we're really in the right place
it's such a good energy here
i think it's a very chaotic energy
yeah a lot of patrick de paris energy
it's necessarily
good
i mean i think it's like i think it's
like really i think it actually it is
good because it's like changing a lot of
things
it's like it's promoting a lot of change
but it's like sometimes hard to keep up
with i'm like wow this is like so much
happening
yeah this city just keeps on pushing
stuff you can't be certain of anything
everything's changing all the time
you're like oh i thought this was the
new spot i guess
you know chupacabra isn't gonna be
a part of the austin comedy scene or
shakespeare's it's such a trippy cobra
so much potential
you were that's chosen one you can do
real comedy
you were the chosen one not like these
[ __ ] shows at
the paramount theater
chupacabra is where you go if you want
to see real people doing real
art
like is that real art you slept with my
girlfriend leo konopka remember that
yeah
i don't even know who that was
that was uh
this other kid
is he gone from the scene now
i guess
he was shamed out
he was trying to shame leo
but yeah chupacabra was one of the first
mics i did here and now it was like in
the bar
like it was just a bar and we were just
performing in the corner there was no
lighting
and the tvs were on
the bartender was pissed that no one was
buying anything
it was a weird vibe
yeah it wasn't it wasn't very
kind on the eyes
it was a terrible place to do comedy
it wasn't there's a lot of those yeah
like what
a lot of like bars like
like wonderlust
and lucky duck
blind pig and
stuff like that blind pig was so bad
i mean people were listening but there
was a lot of people there yeah like
a lot of people yeah it was a good
practice honestly it was really good
practice yeah
it was good at yelling it's like wii
sports
yeah
the crowd was like
sometimes you could get them and it's
like you're practicing like looking at
the people that were actually paying
attention
because it's so loud that if you're
sitting in the front you can't not pay
attention
so you had those people but then
everyone in the back would be partying
and it's like a mental game like how
much positive feedback do you need to
keep doing comedy because you're not
gonna get much here
i actually i got like
i i mean i thought it was better than
other mics where you just don't get
anything at all yeah where it's nobody
yeah at least there's noise and you can
just kind of like
say you're set into the the void of
noise
into the people's
heads it's like easier in a way where
you're just like oh there's noise going
on it's not just me bombing in silence
there's all this ambient noise to take
away from the fact that i'm bombing
um
that's what i like is when i'm bombing
is for other things to be going on
yeah so i perform at basketball games
mostly just so there's a distraction if
i bomb
the distraction is you doing comedy
oh you guys are distracted by the main
event when you came here you guys aren't
distracted
you just showed up with a speaker we're
playing basketball
you guys are not paying attention doing
what we came here to do
what do you guys have atd
why aren't you listening to me what
what's wrong with you
that's so ridiculous you ever done
pop-up comedy like that where it's just
you and you pop up and do comedy yeah
like in my van i showed up when killed
tony was in front of antones i showed
you my van and did it in front of the
shawarma place
and nobody could hear it
uh
in the line but at the shawarma place
there were these two kids listening and
they're like what's your instagram and i
gave them my instagram that's cool maybe
they're listening right now yeah if
you're from the shawarma place in front
of anton shawarma
holler holler in the comments
hopefully we'll read it put a
uh
shawarma in the comments
so i say gyro now that i lived in new
york
yeah and i come here and i say gyro and
they're like oh you're so uncultured
that's not how you say it yeah i'm so
cultured
that's why i say gyro
i think i think there's a lot of things
in new york where they just kind of make
it up and then if the other new yorkers
don't follow
they shame them
yeah like
you have to say houston you gotta say
yeah
you gotta say this
you gotta say gramercy
yeah
and it's like i think it's like a new
york thing
they just make pronunciations it's
definitely not just
it
i mean yeah
but you wrote it's like you're using
like english letters in the english
language
and in the english english language g
doesn't make a euro sound what do they
say what do they they correct you yeah
euro
euro that's what i used to say that's
what i thought yeah that's what it is in
greece
yeah yeah yeah i thought like i would i
well i think like a lot of people in new
york running shawarma's
shawarma trucks
probably aren't from that country i
don't know
yeah
maybe they are
but at first i thought they were like i
was like uh can i get a euro and
i thought they were like being like oh
like
no no no no you say gyro like because
you're
you say gyro i say euro don't say
nicaragua just say nicaragua
and uh yeah gyro it's funny my mom will
like be at like
uh like
foreign restaurants or like mexican
restaurant and she'll like she'll say
everything in english except like one
word
and then where she like over pronounce
it she'll be like yeah i'll have the
rice and beans cheese enchiladas
um and the uh pico de gallo
she's like
just do one or the other
she wants to throw one in there
she wants to she's like dabbling she's
dipping her toe in impressions and
accents
yeah but it's like uh just do just do it
for the whole time or don't do it at all
hello could i have some water and some
pico de gallo
and some extra tortilla chips thank you
so much because you say it in a spanish
accent doesn't mean you're speaking
spanish
it is spanish though pico de gallo
oh yeah i guess but like everything else
yeah can i have some uh
hola can i have a tortilla
it's like you're just doing a spanish
accent you're not
speaking spanish
yeah do you think people go to
mcdonald's in mexico and they're like
hola quiero
hamburger
they're like that's really inappropriate
excuse me i speak spanish i'm not an
uneducated filthy american
yeah um
also like one time we went to queue back
for some reason they queue back
you know quebec quebec
quebecois cubic
we are in
no that's not sorry and uh yeah why they
for some reason that's the only they
just speak french there it's montreal
m-u-n what's quebec quebec
what is that quebec it's a province in
uh canada
yeah we went to quebec
quebec
you're saying queue back it was three
cubic
leaders
yeah yeah went to cuba cubectcha lined
up the queue
ball to the queue back we went to a q
anon meeting and q back
q sent me take you back
and i hit a p
pull q
and we went to quebec and uh
um
my mom was like trying to order a
sandwich at subway and she was like
trying to speak french she was like on
uh a sandwich bucket
like
like three minutes into it the guy was
like dude i speak english
so he's like she's just like struggling
for three minutes
and yeah i mean
it's in canada
most of them are bilingual yeah
but he was just like i guess like trying
to give her a chance
yeah
bucket oh you want to try the french
thing
it's fun i guess
why is this racist
against quebecois quebecois is it
possible to be racist against french
people because they're like really
mean
that's kind of racist
is it possible to be racist against
black people because they steal a lot
how could you be racist against someone
who's so unpleasant that's just natural
human selection
you'd be racist against such an awful
race
that's god's will everything about them
is you can't be racist
it's difficult to be racist against the
french
how can you be racist against french
canadians that's a choice they were like
let us
be weird and different for no reason
yeah
yeah
like
move to canada like the most like
neutral place in the world
we really need to figure out
how to get the camera to go
i know
there's like this program you can
download but it doesn't work the matrix
i could get like an actual video
camcorder
that's 4k
that'd be nice do you ever have a flip a
flip camera
yeah those are cool
yeah they're like bricks
those are like those are like made for
like cairns because you can just like
start recording right away on this
little thing it's one button i gotcha
yeah we gotta fix a lot of this
this is not good this is amateur hour
actually all we need is like a good
camera and then more mics like this but
you do you even like these mics because
you never use this one
i like holding it
you feel like a comedian
i feel like someone holding
a sturdy mic
you like when people do this
i hate it me too
it's so unnecessary
it's like you don't need to do that it's
like you're trying to like make it the
thing like every little thing you have
to do uniquely you can't just [ __ ]
hold the mic you gotta
like you're trying to be creative
in the wrong areas
bill bear holds the mic like this
it just seems like it's bad for the mic
and the cable
yeah it's like i think it's called a uh
a taiwanese grip
this is the uh cat skills i double i
double fisted sometimes
sometimes i hold it like this
or it's just dangling like a boxing
announcer
so uh you ever read to the dentist
it sounds more nasally
like shouting upwards
yeah i mean
you could hold it like a rapper
sometimes i do comedy for god
hey god so
evan that must be nice
heaven on earth
um
yeah but uh it's
it's really nice weather and uh
what are you um are you excited for the
winter in your van
yeah
i think the winter is gonna be better
than the summer
it's so hard to cool something down but
to heat it up is easier
[Music]
that kind of makes yeah that makes sense
as if you're insulated yeah
i just have a heater
yeah and i can watch i i can charge up
my solar panels
although it's less sun yeah
yeah you're gonna
your solar panels are gonna have to get
up early
they're just sitting up there
um hail i'm worried about hail
i know satan
yeah i'm worried about
hail hitler
hail hitler it's just hitler hale
it's just
nazi hale
i did not see that hale hitler coming
it's just hail the the size of hitler
it's like his statue
hell's cool
yeah it's like it's kind of like
like a it's kind of like when clouds are
constipated
they just have like a really hard [ __ ]
i ate too much because it's just like
it's like concentrated
matter it's like
rather than snow it's just like natural
like
yeah
that's like a steady trinkle trickle
yeah it's like
it's like a woman coming it's just like
oh
yes
but hale is like
you gotta like
[ __ ] concentrate
you know hail is actually like the rain
comes down but then there's an updraft
the air goes up so the rain goes up and
then it gets stuck in like the high and
it freezes
i thought it was just like um because
like the pressure was
stronger yeah so like it made it more of
a hard thing
yeah like
there's so much pressure on the cloud
it's like
though all the water gathers up and
drops nice
i don't know maybe that's another way
maybe there's multiple ways to make hail
i wonder if a cloud ever like you know
you know when you have to pee really
hard and you're like you're like you're
like in your car you're almost on you're
like i like i need to hold it i need to
hold it
but then like you know sometimes you go
to the bathroom it starts like coming
out a little bit
before you know you get to the toilet
yeah
or like not even that but like
you feel like you're trying to save it
safety mechanism lift up it's like
and you have one last thing but you can
feel like the gates opening up yeah yeah
yeah and you're trying to save it for
like a certain area to let go i wonder
if clouds do that they're like
i really like this town i don't want to
rain on that
they're like i need to hold it but then
they sometimes they can't hold it and
they're like oh
you're very much cloud-like
it's like yeah i'm like i should imagine
you're a clown
when you're [ __ ] like angel cake like
oh i'm just floating
um
i very much doubt that water has
sentience or human personalities well
that's very rude
um but yeah i mean
that's it's like
like when the pressure over a certain
area is so high they're like all packed
up and tight they're like oh i hate this
i can't wait to let go yeah like when
they reach like sunny pastures like
yeah release now i can get back to
being a cloud
number this isn't real cloud work this
is besmerching the good name of clouds
everywhere
we're meant to float in the air and
harmlessly
reminds you of
sheep and random
farm animals because of our shape do you
think like the cumin on
the nimbus clouds are like
like probably like the athletes
and like the stratus clouds are like
little like
and then the fat clouds they're like
this the service clouds like the ones
the stringy ones are just like
i like like little like fairy like
they're not gay necessarily but like
they're like
they're with wispy
yeah they're like
i wanna
bake muffins
they're like oh there's a strong wind
gotta go bye wee yeah
that's like me i would be like a maybe
like a big service cloud yeah like a gay
cirrus cloud
why why am i gay in cloud form but not
in uniform
i mean that's what i'm saying is you're
gay
uh thanks
uh
but uh that's what leonarda said
on kill tony yeah
she went up after yeah she knows me
really well
they hate chicks what can i say you're
not turned on by me you're [ __ ] gay
i do think she's a beautiful woman
yeah
maybe you could you would do well with
like a strong
female
yeah
just yeah
someone who needs
someone who commands me
to come
come
you bastard
okay i mean if you say so
what
do you want to talk about massages right
now or no
sure yeah i got jerked off by asian
masseuse
and uh it's not funny at all actually
it's actually kind of racist that you
went to an asian
what what do you want me to do i i would
rather not go into an agent
you wanted to go to a white person yeah
like a latina really
no i'm just joking i think part of it is
it's hot that it's like a subjugated
race
but there's like uh
you think it's hot yeah cause it's like
there's nothing she could have done to
avoid it it's like written in the stars
that she was gonna jerk me off
um
written in the stars
it's the way of the world written in
nations
mexicans make tacos and
your mom sucks my dick
um
yeah i mean it was like very like
there's only asian massages
that's like i guess that's like a thing
we cornered the market people's try to
jerk each other off we're like no that's
what we do that's our thing
back off
i'm jerking this guy off
don't even think about touching a dick
we love doing that
it reminds him of
rolling up a sushi
roll
oh
[Music]
um
yeah she
jerked me off as seaweed
was it like because you have a hard time
coming so why was this that was really
easy why was this different i think
because i was in a rush i got an
appointment
oh man i gotta
be out here in a couple minutes
um
and
it was like very
it wasn't intimate at all
so you you don't like intimacy so it's
like you know
you appreciated the business like just
yeah it was like a
factory yes
very well
just sign here
and sign here
i hereby certify that
i would like to be jerked off to
completion
um i would
request a lawyer for this part
there was a lawyer present the whole
time she's in the corner the briefcase
can you sign this in your [ __ ] please
and come here
and right here
and um
yeah
that's hot
uh
yeah it was like uh
it was um
i asked her to like finish the massage
after she turned me off
i was like
are we gonna do a full 30 minutes or
and uh she was like
no
definitely not i just tried because how
do you go back to a massage after that
oh wow this feels nice not as nice as
the thing before but this is good you uh
gnawing on my thigh remind me of the
time you touched my dick and rubbed it
back and forth
with slippery lubrication
between you and i
yeah and i was like laying on the mat
laying on the mat
and then i was like
you know they probably don't clean this
are you on the floor no
i don't know what they call it the the
bed type of thing where you put yourself
in the hole
yeah it's so weird
it's like your head's in like a hole but
you flipped over for the jerk off right
yeah
a machine picked me up
and flipped me over
you're like a [ __ ] panini press
that's just me being lifted by like a
crane
it's just all flying jerk of
that machine
that's awesome though because it's like
uh sometimes i'll be getting a hand job
from like a person that i met in real
life like a date and i'll be like this
isn't as good as that one time i got
jerked off in an asian massage parlor
like for some reason that's hotter
um
because that's all they do that's all
you know them as yeah it's just jerking
you off like
your date you know them as like this
whole complete person
yeah
and that gets in the way yeah you're
like
she likes blueberry yeah
you're like trying to remember her
favorite movies and stuff yeah like i
can't forget that she's a human being
but like
if you can just be like oh someone's
touching my dick
oh there's just this sensation on my
dick then you can concentrate on that
and
yeah and it's also like
um that's the only thing that's gonna
happen it's like you know you there's an
expectation
and you're not like oh what what if we
[ __ ] afterwards or something it's like
it's uh i don't know it's just more
uh
more
you know like you know what's gonna have
everything's structured there's not like
this open-ended
oh we're just stumbling upon different
activities yeah there's a schedule yeah
so which is good because you know it
keeps you
you know you're in that moment you're
like i'm here i'm doing the feature
presentation this is the headliner
yeah so there's nothing else i should
expect and then you could actually be in
the moment because like you're like oh
this is what i'm doing right now
i'm gonna try yeah i think that's why
people like paying for things
is because like they know they're like
this is a transaction like i i'm going
to get this in return and i know i'm
going to get it because i paid you
yeah
rather than just like
i don't know
some like volunteering or some [ __ ]
yeah
seeing something free
getting something for free
like you know
it's like a place has like oh we have
like free lasagna and then you get up
it's just like a little tiny like piece
of lasagna and you're like i would
rather just pay for a big piece of
lasagna
yeah
that ever happened to you yeah the
samples are too small
yeah
they're like uh
like you show up to a pizza party and
the pieces are like this thin
yeah and you're like
the pizza's already cut don't cut it
more
don't cut it into another pizza
just get two pizzas
yeah
yeah i mean
sample sizes you know like
free things
but yeah sex sex is good
i wore a condom when i had sex today
lambskin
no just
hgb hgb condom yeah they make condoms no
it's like trojan or like a brand whoa
those are expensive high roller
like the ones that i had before
uh were tighter but they were harder to
put on and i could never figure it out
like which side i would always [ __ ] it
up like a usb you're like is it this
side or this side i always put it in the
wrong way
but then this one is like baggier and
easier to put in but it's not as tight
which is annoying
um baggy it was baggy yeah
it felt a little baggy
it's like a burlap sack
it was like there was sloppage there was
like there's slack maybe it was used
previously
yeah
it was a
yeah it was a big condom maybe uh
maybe i'm getting smaller yeah well
maybe the day we're getting older so
i'm losing dick mass
shrinking
[ __ ]
drinking more pineapple juice or
something
yeah i mean uh sex
um
i was gonna finger
her but then i ended up not fingering
her because she was like it's already
beat up
beat up yeah like sore
um
well you like before you were just like
i'm gonna finger you after this don't
worry
that's what you said no i usually finger
before because
i like control it's a nice appetizer
yeah it's like
it's quick it's right there you know
it's easy to do
starts it off right yeah you can control
every movement
and you know
it's like when you see a girl that's
like my first instinct this is just like
rubber [ __ ]
anyways instinct
uh wow
um
yeah i mean it's like yeah touching is
definitely like the fir that's like
first base or second base yeah
it should be it should be first base
touching yeah kissing should be second
base i know because kissing is like
really a lot
yeah
it's like
some girls like some girls will have sex
with you and not even kiss you
because like kissing is like so romantic
you gotta concentrate yeah and it's like
it's like yeah it's like intimate
yeah you have to like
put on a play you're like thinking
the right thoughts to make it romantic
oh we're kissing like this and it means
that
yeah you got you like you're working
together and
that's how i guess
yeah
it's a
it's a
it's like a participatory
it's like you're playing tennis girls
are so bad at kissing
yeah
well some people have small lips
yeah they can't kiss very well girls
because like
it's like give me a little bit
more
yeah i'm like i'm doing like lunches
with my lips like
i like i warm up
and yeah yeah yeah
what if you got one up to a girl into
that with her
both of you
that would be nice
i would like that it's like a massage
it's a lawnmower
um it's like electric kissing
kissing is really hot
girls are awesome
yeah um
fingering
um yeah
so uh
what should we do for the last 10
minutes
um how about we have an entertaining
podcast for the last nine minutes just
as a special treat to the listeners wow
i think they would really enjoy that
yeah let's make it listen
yeah let's actually have energy
for the last nine minutes
that's about all i can do
yeah
i mean
austin comedy is like so awesome and i
feel like everyone should come here
that way i don't have to go to new york
or la
and all the people will come here
and it's free of all the old
infrastructure and gatekeepers and if
you like that [ __ ]
if you like
you know people getting in your way and
having to kiss their ass if you're only
skills kissing your ass kissing ass
then you might like the old way of doing
things but if you actually want like a
place you might be texting of
meritocracy and like pure art and comedy
then this is where you should be
you might want to move to texas
unless you want some [ __ ] andrew
cuomo donald trump [ __ ] in new
york to be like
no
i control what happens and i deem that
you're not worthy but this guy i love
this guy look he says whatever i want
what a nice guy if you want to be that
guy then la or new york is for you oh
like the hi
yeah let's that sounds good
yeah
oh i wrote these jokes that are in line
with what you believe and they're all so
clean i'm a clean comic
and i just think it needs to be a safe
space for all
and no don't say anything mean
do not be mean
and
be funny
they're like they're like they say all
these rules and then they're like you
know just be funny like how you just
gave me all these [ __ ] rules
yeah
they're like oh if i just write in the
rules they'll follow it
they think people are robots they can
just tell us
they don't know how uh humor works
yeah
all i've seen is like
i don't know the view or some [ __ ]
i mean i think new york and la are great
cities i don't mean to talk [ __ ] about
them
i think austin is great they have good
restaurants
yeah they're better at being cities
they're actually like laid out for it
good road
yeah
but i think that
um uh
you played katan yesterday
oh yeah patrick department
would you be sorry
i mean because you're always asking me
to play katan and then i never do it and
then you go off and cheat on me
you
[ __ ]
you could tan [ __ ]
uh well i wanted to play the other night
should we take some questions
sure
for the last five minutes
all right now we'll be taking questions
on instagram live so if you have any
questions feel free to comment them
we'll be answering questions about
penises
we'll be answering questions about
comedy
and we'll be answering questions about
homosexuality
[Music]
and religion
politics sports
theater uh archery history politics
um
let's see when that happens on the
instagram live swimming
i think it's delayed by i get a bit oh
there we go it's about 10 seconds
delayed okay so the question should be
rolling in right now all right the
question should be uh
basically
you know
look at all these people joining you
guys might have creeps enjoying your
souls
whoa
wow is that like uh
i know it's
foot souls
but maybe they're talking about our
souls maybe they're sapiosexuals
maybe they're
really profound
and probably a creep staring at our
souls
it looks like you're hey my div my
breasts are up here
my soul down here
my soul's in my
soul pouch okay somebody ask a question
somebody said johan's huge fan
hey hans do you still live in your van
yes
next question
[Laughter]
it's right outside
i can give you a tour later yeah we
should do a van tour of your van
yeah maybe we could do a house tour
so katana is fun because it's like
structured and it's like boring and it's
just like simple and it's like
you get to look at your friends
and you don't have to talk unless you
want
to um
yeah
and you also live in a van
um you do that in a house
i live in a van it's pretty cool
uh you know
i have like a little setup
and i just sleep in there mostly and it
gets dark
right now it's a little hot um
uh it's a little messy right now there's
condom wrappers everywhere and like my
clothes are in a pie you've been eating
condoms yeah it's just been eating
condoms just
you know rip apart the the packaging and
stuff
um but yeah living in a van i park in
front of riley's house someone says tell
me your favorite oh rogelim de santos
said uh
tell me your favorite meat can you grill
in your van
thanks roger
i have an induction stovetop i cook ribs
pork ribs st louis style pork ribs
mostly
and then if i have to i do chicken
quarters
i eat that and i just leave it in my
little stove top stove whatever
like it's like a
it's like that big i pile it in
put the lid on do you ever like touch
the meat and go like yeah that's nice
yeah
i try to get it
to how however i want it
um but yeah i have a little induction
stovetop i also have a pro butane stove
and a propane stove it takes both
but i recently upgraded to a
i got a fancy inverter
that takes higher loads and a bigger
battery
and i got two solar panels is a load
bearing it takes a lot of energy to use
induction stovetops so
now i can use it it uses magnets to heat
up the pot the pan
whoa really uses magnets yeah how
because it gets it back and forth
and it creates heat yeah whoa
yeah
and how much cost uh the thing's like 40
bucks 30 bucks
then the inverter is like 200 bucks and
whatever but i use the inverter for
other things
someone says uh garlic or onion
nothing just me i just put meat in it
you don't like garlic
i mean i've never done a lot of it
on on meat before
costco polish dogs
i haven't eaten that
um
do you get to take your
van out to
national parks after the kill tony
success
before the kill tony's success yes
after no
i've been stuck in the city going up on
secret shows and opening up for tony
hitchcliff and joe rogan so
i mean i guess i don't do that all the
time
but
uh yeah i'm i'm here in the city i enjoy
stand-up comedy i enjoy living out there
too but i i enjoy this more
being a part of society and acting like
i can i'm a part of it and i can help
where it goes i like being a part of
society but being out there is fun too
because you can just really like being a
part of society yeah
if i'm not i'm like what am i doing with
my life i'm just an individual alone but
here like i have purpose even though
it's just to make people laugh and
distract them
do you ever want like a more of a
purpose
yeah i want to be better at this and
actually podcasting yeah dictate where
our society goes i feel like we don't
get to to
decide as millennials yeah i know i was
like looking around and i just like saw
all this like electrical wire and all
these like cell phone towers and [ __ ]
and i'm like we had no say in this yeah
we like these just these are just here
like the go the government is deciding
to put these up for us like they're like
yeah they'll probably want this yeah no
i don't can you explain how this works
and like oh
we just did it you don't have to know
just [ __ ] go to chipotle and spend
your money and go to work and
consume and be a part of the economy you
don't have to actually be a part of it
you just have to do your part in like
consuming
someone said have you read harry potter
yes
i loved harry potter five-year-old girl
who said that it's such an easy book to
read it like flies by
maybe it's like the paragraph
indentation or something but when does
the q a begin it's begun
it's happening
um would hans participate in the squid
game
wait that's korean right yeah
you guys are making a lot of good movies
i know
we are
i think it's a combination of it's a
very artistic culture like they had a
lot of theaters and plays and kabuki
masks and whatever
kabuki and also a love of american
technology and
whatever
but uh squid game i would not
participate in it because i live in a
van i don't need that much money i'm
doing what i want with my life i don't
need to have money to do what i i'm
doing right now
um
and i'm not financially desperate
because i have very few financial needs
so
um
yes i do not want to play the squid game
but if things were dire if i had a child
that needed
leukemia medicine or if i uh you know
was in dire financial straits or just to
give myself a better life i mean
i think the thing about those movies is
like everyone's suffering
uh financially to some degree or a lot
of people are and it's for no one we're
just suffering pointlessly living in
shitty conditions and going hungry and
at least if you're in the squid game
people are watching you're suffering and
enjoying it there's purpose to the
suffering
but what's unbearable is suffering for
nobody and for no reason so if i could
allay my current suffering into a more
popular entertaining version of
suffering maybe that would help
psychologically
uh
squid do they when does the squid come
who's running the game try not to get
raped by the squid
try to rape a squid
you're in a swimming pool
it's a game of squid um does it worry
you that strangers you kiss on stage
might have coveted or other health
concerns
like aids
i added that part
i mean no i honestly think most people
are clean and that most people are not
that dirty
and that kissing them is fun
good immune system
um that's the real squid game all right
all right well
uh
should we
make some jack-o-lanterns or
yeah let's make like jack-o'-lanterns
and start
tracking
a lantern
what is it called that thing that
christy was talking about in south
africa jack rolling jack roll
let's go jack jackson thugs
jack
oh
lope
jackalope
jack timmons
all right well uh
i need to go
shave and
my body
and my body
and my body is
being falling apart as we speak
thank you guys and have a good night
thank you so much and watch squid game
make sure to
support your local squid
game and sign up a participating
location sign up for our squid game at
www.hanzasvanofterror.com
it's so
dystopian all right
peace